bitcoin's price has dropped by 50
or so since the all-time high of 69 000
back in november but bitcoin holders
don't care at all what am i talking
about well what we can see is because
bitcoin is a open transparent blockchain
we can see exactly what everyone is
doing and here's the bitcoin balance on
exchanges this gray line is the actual
price of bitcoin the gold line is
exactly how much bitcoin is on exchanges
and what you can see is that since the
high in july of 2021 there has been more
and more bitcoin coming off of these
exchanges the reason why this is
important is because the more bitcoin on
the exchange the more likely people are
to sell but if you're taking the bitcoin
off the exchange you're a long-term
holder you're accumulating you're
holding for the long term and you are
not looking to sell and so regardless of
bitcoin's price going up or down more
and more bitcoin has been coming off of
exchanges for the last eight months or
so now we also can look at exactly what
those long-term holders are doing we can
identify them on the blockchain and what
we see is that the total supply held by
long-term holders has been increasing
since about november we've been holding
very steady even though bitcoin has gone
down about 50 percent that's an
important detail because the short-term
holders are capitulating they're selling
to the long-term holders but don't just
take it from me we've got this quote
here which comes from the folks over at
global block marcus says the percentage
of bitcoin on exchanges continues to
decrease since the all-time high at 69
000 glass node shows that 42 900 bitcoin
has left exchanges these indicators
suggest that as the price has decreased
by over 50 percent over the past few
months whales have been accumulating
while short-term holders are
capitulating now of course the
transparent ledger of bitcoin tells us a
lot of information you wouldn't get in
the legacy markets and what is important
to realize is that the long-term holders
the veterans the people have been around
they're unfazed by 30 40 50 drawdowns in
price they realize this is a long-term
game bitcoin is a game of accumulation
and the whales the long-term holders
those strong hands they have been
accumulating aggressively since the
all-time high as bitcoin falls they
continue to bot as bitcoin falls and the
short-term holders keep selling they get
panicked they get worried they are in an
uncertain environment they simply are
dumping their bitcoin well who the hell
are they dumping it to they're selling
it right to the veterans they're selling
it to long-term strong hands and those
bitcoin whales those people have been
around for a long time are happy to buy
your bitcoin at a 30 40 50
decrease